Recently we've been focusing on
climate change in California's Sierra Nevada
where about 60% of the state's
water resources come from.
To get climate change projections
in the Sierra Nevada right
we have to incorporate a process
that we call snow albedo feedback.
All surfaces have a property called albedo.
It's the degree to which the surface reflects sunlight.
You've encountered the effects of albedo when you've walked across an asphalt surface on a hot sunny day.
Dark surfaces like asphalt and soil
absorb more sunlight and get warmer.
Light surfaces like snow reflect
more sunlight and stay cooler.
So what happens with climate change in a snowy place?
Temperatures rise and snow melts.
At the snow margins, where snow is often
shallow, it melts completely.
And snow cover retreats.
Now we have a land surface that
used to be covered in snow but now is not.
That newly exposed land surface has a lower albedo.
So it absorbs a lot more sunlight
and that area gets even warmer.
the extra warming causes more snow to melt
and snow cover retreats even further.
This creates a circular process
known as a positive feedback.
If you want to model future climate accurately,
You have to incorporate positive feedbacks
like snow albedo feedback into your research.
California's snowpack is already
experiencing the effects of climate change.
We found that in recent years, in both dry and wet years,
the snowpack is already reduced because of the warming that has occurred over the past century.
So even when we have a big water year
and it seems like there's a lot of snow,
there's actually less snow than there
would be without this warming.